when there was a meeting of negotiators in Istanbul,
there was one geography and
our willingness to accept the Ukrainian
proposal was based on that geography on the
geography of the end of March
2022, now the geography is different,
this is far from being only the DPR Lanner, it is
also the Kherson region, the Zaporozhye region
and a number of other territories, and this process
continues
[music]
we cannot allow that in
that part of Ukraine that Zelensky will
control
there or who will replace him
there is a weapon that
will pose a direct threat to
our territory and the territory of those
republics that have declared their
independence and those who want to
determine their future  stand by myself and
[music]
whom I will beat
I facts brought in the people everything that I chose
to do it in order to